[Music]
altered states refers to a mode of
consciousness or awareness that takes us
out of our ordinary everyday sense of
the world sense of ourselves we can
enter altered states when it would get
intensely focused on something deep
concentration will bring you into an
altered state sometimes people like to
talk about how athletes get into the
zone or they get into flow those are all
everyday altered states but they come
from being intensely focused on some
activity or in the moment itself and of
course altered states can come from
drugs or from being in an unusual
physiological state a fever can bring on
an altered state and of course the 60s
and 70s saw a huge upsurge of people
interested in exploring altered states
through psychedelics so altered states
are temporary conditions when whatever
it was that brought on the special state
of awareness leaves then the state fades
so you know if you get into a flow state
rock climbing when you come down from
the mountain it's gone or whatever may
may have caused that your temperature
might have gone up and put you in doing
maybe not a pleasant altered state but
still an altered state temperature goes
down it's gone
altered traits on the other hand are
lasting changes or transformations of
being and they come classically through
having cultivated an altered state
through meditation which then has a
consequence for how you are day-to-day
and that's different than how you were
before you tried the meditation and what
we find in our research as we say in the
book alter traits is that the more you
meditate the more lifetime hours you put
into it the stronger the lasting traits
becoming when we surveyed the you know
the more than 6,000 peer-reviewed
articles published today on meditation
we use very strict rigorous
methodological stay
we winnow them down to about 60 so maybe
1% of all those articles were really
well done and they document very
strongly that altered traits are a
lasting consequence of regular
meditation and it's not that it's the
altered states that's the point if you
look at the classic traditions from
which meditation comes to us in the West
all of them talk about the quality of
being the person you become and we see
it in the data in many ways we see it in
cognitive changes we see it in
behavioral changes and most importantly
we see it in neurological changes the
neuroscience of meditation is really
getting stronger and stronger it's
pretty spectacular and it shows that
brain function and perhaps even
structure in long-term meditators
becomes different and becomes different
in ways that are actually predicted in
classic meditation texts now the good
news is that there's a dose-response
relationship in meditation and
apparently from what we can tell the
longer you do it the more benefits you
get so for example right from the
beginning their attentional benefits
their stress benefits you're more
resilient under stress but we see this
even more strikingly in people who have
been longer term meditators people who
have done meditation daily for say
several years there you see in terms of
attention things that don't show up with
the beginners so much you see that for
example they're more present there's a
strict esta vez in cognitive science
called the attentional blink the
attentional blink means you get lost in
one thought and you don't notice what's
happening the next moment and this
happens of course to all of us
ordinarily but longer term meditators
seem to have this less that means
they're more present to the moment
longer term meditators are able to
better focus in the midst of
distractions this is
a kind of common sense because
meditation in essence is training in
attention the basic move in meditation
is you're focusing on one thing or on a
particular attentional stance the
mind-wandering circuitry which is well
known in neuroscience the mind-wandering
circuitry kicks in people's mind wander
on average 50% of the time research at
Harvard tells us and so at some point
when you're trying to do your meditation
your mind will wander we're wired that
way the key is do you notice that it
wanders once you notice your mind has
wandered off and you bring it back
you're strengthening the circuitry for
focus for attention and just like going
to the gym and working out for a long
you know years and years doing reps you
get bigger muscles and more strength and
fitness the same thing happens in the
mind the mind is a mental gym and
meditation is a basic workout so if
you're a long-term meditator you get
more benefits than people who are just
starting out it's just common sense and
we see it in the scientific findings so
longer term meditators are better able
to focus on that one thing and not be
distracted even when there's a hubbub
around them they're better able to
concentrate they're better able to be
present to what's happening so the
attentional benefits just get stronger
and stronger and even more important
they become traits we see them not when
a person is meditating but months after
or just in their everyday life when when
they come into a lab without meditating
we see that the attentional benefits
still last the same thing is true of
stress in long-term meditators the
benefits for handling stress gets
stronger and stronger as time goes on of
course we see some signs of this in
people right from the get-go beginners
and meditation but the longer you've
been a meditator the more for example
you're able to snap back from
upset and this is called this is really
the sign of resilience the resilience is
measured scientifically by how long it
takes you to get back to what we call
your baseline that pleasant mood you're
in before that thing flipped you out and
that the shorter that is the more
resilient you are and we see this as a
lasting trait in long-term meditators
they are able to bounce back from stress
and also we see that their amygdala that
trigger point for the stress reaction is
less reactive they're calmer in the face
of stress so the stress benefits get
stronger and stronger and become traits
in long-term meditators
[Music]